the news from wednesday was a reminder
that
we still have to kind of hold our breath
a little bit but
but i think we're getting closer and
closer and closer to the point where we
can exhale and say let's enjoy
the super bowl and when we do we may see
number 81 in
pewter and white and that would be
antonio brown tom brady yesterday in
his latest media session was asked about
brown
and the work that brown has done to put
some not all that long ago
ugliness in his rear view mirror here's
brady on brown
antonio and i correct connected right
away and
he has a great love for the game uh is a
real perfectionist
about how he plays how he takes care of
himself
incredible football iq
and then again a great skill set just as
a player and
i think made incredible strides over the
last 12 months to get
from where he was at to where he's at
now
well i think one of the reasons he made
incredible strides chris is because tom
brady decided
i am going to get directly involved in
getting this guy
pointed in the right direction and this
isn't a charity case
by tom brady we've talked about this
before if antonio brown wasn't antonio
brown
he's not going to be living at tom
brady's house he's not out here looking
for wayward individuals that he can try
to help their
turn their lives around this is a guy
that can help tom brady
get to where he wants to be which is the
top of the mountain for the seventh time
so because of that connection they made
during their brief time together in new
england in september
of 2019 tom brady was willing
to do what he had to do to speak to
antonio brown's better angels
to get antonio brown to avoid
self-inflicted wounds
to get antonio brown ready to contribute
to the football team and when called
upon he has
yeah no he has yeah certainly i'm sure
there's selfish reasons there for brady
you know wanting to uh keep the
friendship alive or
be attached to antonio brown i mean
there's no doubt there's nothing wrong
with that i mean as a competitor
hey that's part of competing oh hey i'm
gonna free i'm gonna be a free agent
hey what you're a free agent and you're
good too and whoa if i just stay in
contact with you maybe we can
be on the same team together and you can
help me win more
yes i think there's you know there's
that aspect of course
but i think there is still a human
element here too that i don't think we
can just brush over i do
think that there is a common bond and
you can see it just
there when brady talks or anytime he
talks about antonio brown where
yeah they're maybe their lives are very
very different outside
the walls of football in a football
facility
but the one thing you know about both of
these guys when it comes to football
there's a psychoness in their approach
and their detail and their work ethic
and they live it
and you know brady talked about him
being a perfectionist and being all over
every detail well that's like tom brady
so i'm sure they could hit it off
on a personal level very easily that way
and that helps the friendship along
you know to go along with it so hey i'm
always happy to see a guy
get his life straighten back on you know
the the straight and narrow
that's a good thing even though it's
been some some troubling stuff there's
no doubt about it everybody deserves a
second chance
and even the third chance i'm not even
opposed to that and brady
yeah selfish a little bit okay so what
but i still think it's all a good story
and and glad to see that right you know
they're on the same page
i mean i'm not saying so it's just it's
part of the reality oh i know
i don't know let's let's not fool
ourselves into thinking about this guy
is mother teresa no
he's trying to help himself and and and
i think it's okay to say that he's
trying to help himself win a super bowl
that's why he's been behind i wasn't
attacking you now here all right
now here's the problem here's the
problem before antonio brown can get
redemption he's got to be
ready to be redeemed let's listen to
some of brown
from yesterday and let's ask ourselves
is this is a guy
who really has accepted the fact
that the things that have happened in
his life are more his fault
than someone else's fault he was brown
from yesterday
and tony when you talk about staying
disciplined and doing all the right
things what were some of those
things and what did you learn what did
you change um
to be able to get back to here
well it's all about you know controlling
your emotions
physically mentally when you don't feel
good uh
not being a slingshot when others come
at me you know uh
learning how to control my attitude uh
not letting my emotions get the best of
me
even if i feel someone was wrong for
doing what they did you know just being
forgiving
i just stand staying positive
what do you want your legacy to be and
do you regret
that whole year and a half that you went
through before
this well i want to make my legacy to be
a god i will persistent a god i never
gave up
i'm married to odds i'm murdered hate uh
no matter scrutiny uh no matter what i
went through
uh i want my legacy to be a six-round
kid from central michigan i never gave
up
uh earned everything he got
persevered through every adversity and
uh
a guy who had the will of a champion
some of that stuff at the end was a
flash of other things he said
painting himself as a victim complaining
about the haters
the problems he's gone through the last
two years really ever since we
first found out about the frozen feet
from the cryogenic chamber gone bad
something that you caught wind up before
anyone else remember that july
august 2019 right that's when the
dominoes started to fall for him in a
negative way and we already had known
about
you know the the exit from pittsburgh
and the whole
mr big chest and everything he did to
get out of there but it all settled down
and it looked like it was going to work
with the raiders and that's when it all
just fell apart and it just kept falling
apart and falling apart and the thing
that's still hanging over
the civil lawsuit for sexual assault and
rape
that that look i again the this isn't a
situation where there are haters
there are things that he has done that
has gotten him under scrutiny that has
gotten him into trouble
that had him plead guilty to felony
charges for an altercation
with the driver of a moving truck last
year right around this same time
frame got him suspended eight games the
nfl still hasn't acted against him
on this pending lawsuit and depending
upon how that goes
he could get disciplined again and
frankly if he testifies under oath in
that case in a deposition the way he
behaved
in another lawsuit the one that involved
him throwing furniture
off of a balcony of a high-rise
apartment building
that it's not going to go well for him
he doesn't submit to authority
well he doesn't answer questions well
when challenged by
haters as he would call them that that's
that's the issue that's front and center
and i saw a lot of blowback against him
yesterday and rightfully so
for trying to characterize himself as a
victim chris he's not a victim
he has victimized people allegedly or
actually he's not a victim
no i mean agreed that that's uh you know
that
doesn't make sense hey listen i like the
fact that
he's obviously reflected on the way you
know he's handled himself to a degree
i mean he talked about not letting to
get his emotions get the best of them
we've seen him act appropriately we
haven't even really seen him act out on
the football field in any crazy way
you know like get in people's face or do
anything like that
but yes i mean there does seem to be a
little bit of a lack of compassion as
far as
what he has done to others and
you're in the boat you're in because of
you there's nobody else it's not because
of haters or anything like that
in fact like i would almost go like the
opposite for a long long time
i mean he was just the bed of roses
always for antonio brown he could do no
wrong
hey look at all the fantasy points oh so
what he
he said he was going to punch that espn
reporter's jaw
off who cares he got he got all that
stuff got
he got a free pass for a long time
because he's so charming and has that
great smile and that way of life about
him
so you know you can't cry you know foul
now
uh when you've kind of made the bed
you're sleeping in
that's a great point that is a great
point because it wasn't until
2018 training camp right that happened
somebody from espen had the audacity to
actually
take a closer look at antonio brown take
a closer look
at things that people around him were
saying
and that set him off he directed some
anger at ed bouchette formerly the
pittsburgh post gazette now of the
athletic
and we started to see these little
things that were making us say wait a
minute is this guy who we thought he was
and then it all culminated in the events
that resulted in him
tweeting his way out of pittsburgh and
it just continued into 2019 and and then
it becomes more serious when the guys
sued for sexual assault
and rape and the case is pending and it
goes to trial december
of 2021 and my guess is at some point
this off season
he will be required to go to a
conference room at a lawyer's office
go under oath and answer questions and
based upon his past experiences of
having to submit
to that authority and answer those
questions there's a chance
it will not go well and there's a chance
that that
transcript and that video will get him
in more trouble with the league and or
the buccaneers
assuming he signs a contract to come
back for next year well i mean listen i
agree with you there you've been saying
that from the start about him getting in
front of somebody in the deposition you
could see
just in those two little comments we had
right there
you know you can strike a nerve a little
bit with
certain things to where he went down the
haters
road and all of that type of stuff to
where you go whoa
you know so yes i i understand he's not
out of the woods yet we're gonna see
but glad it's it's going in the right
direction and certainly
it's being helped out by tom brady who's
there to kind of watch over him a little
bit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports